Hey, let's do some Thank You Notes.
James, can I get some Thank You Note writing music, please?
♪♪
-Speaking of holiday spirit.
-He's always -- Look how happy he is.
-Yeah. Wow.
♪♪
-Thank you, last week of the campaign,
for being when fundraising e-mails switch
from polite to hostage taker.
It's like, "Give me 10 dollars!"
♪♪
Thank you, New York City Marathon,
for being the only time it's a great accomplishment
to come in 20th place.
Like -- That's pretty amazing.
♪♪
Thank you, daylight savings time,
or as Taylor Swift calls you,
"Midnights (11 pm edition)."
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Thank you, midterm election ads for being the best gig
in the business for voice actors who say...
[Deep voice] "But is he really who he says he is?"
[ Laughter ]
[ Ominous music plays ]
"Is he really?"
"John Tompkins says he stands for..."
♪♪
Thank you, Jeff Bezos and Jay-Z
considering buying the Washington Commanders,
for being the first time two of the world's richest men said,
"Wanna go halfsies?"
[ Laughter ]
"Go splitzies on this?"
♪♪
Thank you, bowling balls, for always looking like
you just found out what your job is.
-"Oh? Ooh?"
"Ooh! Ohh!"
"Whoa!"
-Yeah, okay.
♪♪
Thank you, letter openers.
Without you, I don't know how anyone
would be able to barely rip paper.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Get it in the slot.
-Thank you, window caulk, for making it look like
I'm turning my real house into a gingerbread house.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Eventually, you'll make it happen.
♪♪
Thank you, Nespresso Pods,
for just being acorns from the future.
There you go, everybody. Those are our Thank You Notes.